the industrial Hub of naranganj dates
back a hundred years it's surrounded by
two major rivers and many canals which
are badly polluted following Decades of
Rapid industrial growth and increasing
urbanization
last year city leaders approved an
action plan for low carbon climate
resilient development it's the first
city in Bangladesh to do that
the mission is to turn narangaran City
into a clean City free from pollution
and keep in mind this is the first time
in Bangladesh we have prepared a climate
action plan to tackle the increasing
rate of emissions along with various
other initiatives like air quality
monitoring energy waste and so on
the city has already built Eco parks
with green zones including forests and
several air monitoring stations as well
as starting to restore canals and
wetlands
the river water is polluted by
Industrial Waste governments need to
take the steps to clean these
major source of pollution include cement
factories illegal break counts and steel
mills the government is funding the
cleanup project along with the help from
Japan the World Bank and Asian
development Bank a recent survey
highlighted how the city has the third
worst air quality in Bangladesh a record
which the government said it intends to
change
regulation on emission and effluent
management are frequently violated due
to lack of enforcement air and water
pollution affects the health and income
of residents
there are still a lot of problems with
various wastes like dust mosquitoes and
other types of pollutants around the
streets the river water is also heavily
polluted there are no fish you can't use
the water the general public suffers
environmental experts say the city has
the potential to become a role model
demonstrating how local governments can
play a vital role in realizing the goals
of the Paris agreement on climate change
tanvi Chaudhary Al Jazeera naranganj
Bangladesh
thank you